ladies and gentlemen could I have your
attention please for the declaration of
results for the Keithley Sutherland and
Easter Ross constituency iced tea pardon
returning officer for the Keithley
Sutherland and Easter Ross constituency
declare that the total number of votes
cast across the constituency at the UK
parliamentary election on the 8th 15
2017 was thirty thousand nine hundred
and thirty six which is a turnout of
sixty six point zero percent the total
number of ballot papers rejected was
thirty-five the total number of votes
given to each candidate was as follows
Olivia Bell Scottish Labour Party 3833
stru and Mackay Scottish conservative
and unionist 6990 whole whole Monaghan
Scottish National Party nine thousand
and seventeen and
Jeanne stone Scottish Liberal Democrats
11,000
therefore I give public notice that
Jeanne stone is duly elected as the
Member of Parliament for the keenness
Sutherland and Easter Ross constituency
and I invite him and the second-place
candidate to speak mr. telling-off so
can i express my deep thanks to you and
staff who have organized this elections
through a highly efficient Lee can I
also say a big thank you to the police
and all others that have been involved
in particular I want to express my
personal thanks to my wife flora and my
children and all the many people who
helped me in the election and also the
many many good wishes I received on the
doorsteps the length and breadth of this
huge constituency it is a source of
colossal Quitely that I have played a
part in relighting the beacon of
liberalism in the highlands
I wish my opponents the very best in the
future ladies gentle I wish you a safe
journey home thank you ladies and
gentlemen I would also like to thank
that a tonig officer on the star the
police for the conduct of the count
which has been exempted I would also
like to thank my colleagues have
supported me in my campaign across the
wonderful constituency of Caithness so
on an Easter goes and I would like to
thank my family above all I would like
to thank the people who voted for me
today it has been a privilege to meet so
many of you over the last two years to
support you to assist you and to help
you
I congratulate mr. stone and all of the
candidates while I've not been elected
my SMP colleagues who have been elected
across the country represent the
continuation were dramatically changed
political landscape in Scotland the
people of Scotland are speaking and it
means time for their voice to be heard
at waste Minster and I know that I will
happen SMP MPs will be a strong voice
for Scotland and both seek to work with
others to help deliver to aggressive
politics across the UK including an end
to austerity they will call for the UK
government to deliver the promises that
have been made to Scotland and they will
fight for a fair deal as the UK it
leaves the European Union the people
were kidneys Sutherland and Easter goes
one a fear and a stronger